i want to know your thoughts on when you
first saw kendrick's video the heart
part five
man
amazing number one you know what i'm
saying i damn near i dare never drop the
tear
you know what i'm saying that [ __ ] was
just when they got to knit part you feel
me it was just
that [ __ ] was crazy the movement the
gestures everything the mannerism
everything like that [ __ ] it should hit
different
you know what i'm saying definitely it
was that words just just what he was
saying like it was you know what i'm
saying some real impacted
[ __ ]
do you uh because when i saw that i was
like okay well obviously
this is a powerful moment first of all
it's the first
music we've heard from kendrick in five
years five years you know what i'm
saying it's the first
it's the first look we get from you know
what i'm saying the first sound we get
from and then for him to
do that was to me like
it's that's a hard thing to do without
it i like it just it i only i feel like
only kendra could have did that yeah you
know what i mean yeah cause i think if
somebody else would have did that
yeah people would have looked at him
like crazy yeah
do you do you happen to know if like he
ran that by like sam or anybody before
it came out or was it kind of like did
everyone hear it when everyone heard it
nah
i mean
[ __ ] like that come from the heart you
know what i'm saying i don't think you
gotta you know what i'm saying run [ __ ]
like that by the team especially you
being kendrick and we you know i'm
saying we [ __ ] with you of course with
the team you home team your family
you feel me um
yeah i think that's something just
straight from the heart you feel me like
i ain't even gonna let nobody even know
i'm doing it y'all gonna see it when
y'all see it yeah yeah yeah it was it
was powerful dude yeah it was crazy
because i also feel like
when that happened you know we didn't
get to hear from kendrick in the turn
like kendrick
we i mean we've been waiting five years
right yeah so when we lost nip man like
you know when we think of la we think a
nip and we think of kendrick yeah
exactly and to like finally kind of
get to hear him
you know put his thoughts in into
anything about just any any yeah but
just that loss like you know it's just
man it's just great it was crazy like
you said it was some real emotional [ __ ]
yeah it was trippy at first i looked at
it i'm like
you know what i'm saying just going
through all the different faces not even
just with nip just yeah kobe
just all of it yeah
super crazy man super crazy